we know you're coming up in Teen Wolf
what are you looking forward to about
that sand what can fans expect I cannot
say anything about the Roland team
because the snipers are out there and
they will take me down they're very big
on their secrecy on Teen Wolf
especially since none of it is aired yet
but it's a really cool character and
apparently I made such an impression and
they're bringing me back for more
it's a very dark very creepy character
of course I mean really but I cannot
really say more but season four is gonna
really really kick butt I mean it's it's
a fun show with a really great group of
people on that show really fun set to
work on and I I'm having a great time
work on it we're shooting right now so
it's gonna be great also the hundreds
been renewed hasn't said can we look
forward to seeing more of you in that I
hope so yeah I mean again I cannot say
too much because we're halfway through
the season now and my carats is gonna be
making his appearance at some point soon
so I don't know give away too much
because obviously it's it's airing right
now but I would love to be back on the
show I mean I know roughly what's gonna
be happening in season two and
everyone's so happy that it's been
renewed because it's such a fun show
it's kind of it's kind of like the CW
version of Game of Thrones ironically
when I went in to audition for the show
the casting director said to me it's
like oh my god when I read these scripts
it kind of felt like I was reading a
script for Game of Thrones it really has
a very dark Game of Thrones element to
it cross it may be Lord of the Flies and
and The Hunger Games it's a really fun
show and I hope it lives long and
I really hope smiie back I thought you
can see live long and prosper though you
did didn't I
that be a crossover star trekkin and the
hundred I don't think anyone will
complain about that
we'll just have something I mean we have
to space Elliman we have you know the
characters on the ground they're like
the Klingons and stuff so yeah yeah we
can make that happen but 100 it's a
fantastic show and Teen Wolf is so much
fun I I play some really yeah I come in
for some damage as usual I don't make
out with a lead girl unfortunately no I
just kill everyone thanks very much
you